stem-related fields are rapidly growing
that's according to the bureau of labor
statistics so what are some ways we can
get our children prepared to work in
this
ever-evolving high-tech world well
joining us now
is oscar pedroso the ceo of thimble
which teaches young people engineering
and programming skills thanks so much
for joining us oscar we appreciate your
time today
thank you so much i appreciate it and
it's lovely to be here
well let's jump right into it for those
who don't know what a stem education is
we've covered a lot of stories here
in town we have quite a few steam
academies as well but if you could
please explain for those who aren't
familiar
sure stem is an acronym and you'll most
often hear it with
other acronyms like steam and stream but
at its very basic
stem stands for science technology
engineering and math
and basically oscar like this is the way
of the future i mean if you want to hook
your kids up get them started early
right
exactly yes these days even
toddlers are they're they're finding
their way to using something that's
technical whether it's a video game or
an ipad
it's getting younger and younger now the
learning curve to learn
what are some ways that we as parents at
home can help our kids with the
stem yeah you know there's there's a lot
out there and it's such a broad term
and it really depends you know
especially on the interests of the child
but if you see that they have an
interest in engineering and robotics
there's a lot that they that they can
actually go to there's
that they're not even products that they
have to buy they can actually use
specific
materials at home um that they can use
to build very very basic projects but
then there's
other more sophisticated projects like
snap circuits
there's uh all different types of
electronic
type toys that they can start using and
it's not just hands on but there's also
a lot of different types of apps as well
that they can use that start introducing
them to coding
and those start becoming a really good
way for kids to just jump in
we've covered a number of stories and i
think the key age if i can remember is
about fifth
sixth grade for the coding does that
sound about right to you
yes and that's a sweet spot uh you can
start younger i mean i've seen
i've worked with schools that start
really at kindergarten
but i would say for them to really
understand what's going on once they
have the
the math and reading abilities fifth
grade is such a great time to start
learning
and then before we let you go tell us a
little bit more about symbol and where
people can go to get some more
information
definitely so thimble is a monthly
subscription that for kids that teaches
them robotics coding and engineering
so it's a curriculum and there's a
progression of about 15 different types
of kits
that teach them all different types of
skills and then from there they're
participating in live classes where
they're usually taught by teachers from
companies like spacex apple microsoft
and then there's also a lesson library
where they can work on projects at their
own pace
wow that is a huge resource all right
well we greatly appreciate your time
today oscar and we hope to do some
follow-ups with you in the future in the
meantime
let people know where they can go for
all that information thank you once
again oscar have a nice start to your
holiday
thank you you too